like Wanda to go for the detention room
is like a cooling chamber with a metal
door escape from this room is impossible
Gianni was one of 200 human rights
lawyers Chinese authorities rounded up
in July 2015
everything inside is wrapped in soft
material the walls the table it's so you
can't kill yourself I didn't see
daylight for half a year a bright light
is on 24 hours a day you don't know if
it's day or night it feels like you've
been locked up in hell you're completely
cut off from the world you don't know
anything and you're terrified to
freaking uganda uncorking CNE was called
to the administration of his apartment
complex he didn't suspect anything
there several plainclothes police were
waiting they blindfolded him and shoved
him into a car
[Music]
his wife and children were wondering why
he didn't come back then later that day
20 police officers came to search their
apartment I was absolutely terrified
nobody told me he clean detained the
police searched the house but refused to
give any information forced
disappearances have become increasingly
common in China the head of Interpol a
former Canadian diplomat an exiled
writer a Canadian businessman an
activist and a photographer a lawyer
Hong Kong booksellers and a billionaire
are just a few of those who disappeared
in the last two years the facilities
often incite military compounds they are
secret but activists have tried to find
some of them detainees are not in the
judicial systems database see Andy's
wife and his mother herself a lawyer
then did everything to track him down
but without success she was even more
terrified than I was she kept asking
where have they taken my son she said
yan you might never come back 22 days
after my husband disappeared she
suddenly died
the uncertainty is intentional
authorities use the sides to extort
confession two guards are present around
the clock they register every movement
you make they observe you to find your
weak spot
and find out what you're most scared
[Music]
they don't allow you to change positions
when you sleep and they deprive you of
your slightest freedoms you have to ask
even if you want to drink water or they
make you sit on a wooden block for
sixteen hours until you can't feel your
limbs anymore you can't even go to the
toilet because your nerves seem dead the
whole detention facility is designed for
you to understand that you were under
their control if they want you to live
you will live if they want you to die
you will die if they want you to suffer
you will suffer if they want you to be
happy you'll be happy Vanya talk quietly
see a Annie's whereabouts were unknown
for six months later he was transferred
to a regular detention center and jailed
for two years after his release he wrote
a detailed account of the secret
detention she even had his license to
practice law revoked but he is still
refusing to keep quiet
that report party abuse Matthias
Bolinger who now joins me from Beijing
but he is firstly how widespread is this
practice of forced disappearances in
China it is becoming increasingly common
that is within the last five years of
course a lot of the things that happen
in these secret detentions have been
common in China torture mental torture
isolation extortion of confessions or
this has been
earning before but this systematic and
comprehensive use of disappearances is
something we have seen during the xi
jinping era manhattan to lawyers to
dissidents it has happened to foreign
nationals it all seems to be modeled on
the treatment of corrupt officials the
communist party usually takes these
people in its control in its own control
after they are expelled from the party
they are handed over to the judicial
system so this is what we see recently
so when someone is disappeared or
vanishes what recourse does the family
have who do they turn to for help well
you can imagine what they do is they try
to find any information possible they go
to state organs prosecutors detention
centers legal criminal detention centers
police stations but they do not get any
information so the only thing that they
can do is to make this public to hope
that the international press that
diplomats become aware of the case and
keep raising this case this might not
really protect their relative or or
release their relative but it might
offer some protection from the worst
abuses this that's at least what they
hope but this is China facing any
international pressure over these
disappearances China is facing pressure
on a lot of individual cases the ones
mentioned in the report they were all
reported by the international press they
have been raised by international
diplomats diplomats appear when they
hear of human rights defendants being
put in court they appear in front of the
court they're never admitted and but
they stand there along with journalists
to show that they care they keep contact
with the relatives all this is happening
but now international organization or
no country has found the means to
convince the Chinese government of
ending these abuses of human rights
right Amity spelling in Beijing thank
you for excellent reporting annual
insights into this practice of enforced
disappearances